der ein mann überlebt einen haiangriff
in australien nur weil er dem hype
kräftig aufs maul haut der mann ist 28
jahre alt heißt film amat und surfte an
der banca bay in westaustralien als er
von einem weißen hai angegriffen wurde
ich saß auf meinem bord und ich erinnere
mich wie ich die kraft spürte mit der
mich derart straff und als nächstes
erinnere ich mich dass ich im wasser war
und mein board in zwei hälften gebissen
wurde
da sagt der server der website magic
suite dann als ich merkte was los war
war mein erster instinkt einfach das
surfbrett in sein maul zu schieben weil
ich dachte wenn er das beißt dann weist
er mich nicht seine freunde beobachten
den kampf mit dem hai und alten dem
surfer zu hilfe sie berichteten dass
film mama dem heim auf den kopf und aufs
mal geschlagen habe offenbar hat das
geholfen und der hai ließ von dem surfer
ab jetzt erholt sich der 28 jährige im
krankenhaus denn er hat den kampf nicht
unverletzt überstanden eine wunde musste
mit 63 klammern geschlossen werden
ja nochmal glück gehabt